[Music]
wreck-it Ralph - managed to break the
internet before the movie even came out
but there are far more details in the
trailer people actually overlooked have
you paid enough attention to Moana to
see this mind-boggling detail don't
forget to hit that notification bell to
never miss another video now let's check
out some details about Moana from
wreck-it Ralph to hanging out with Elsa
and Anna okay we get that Moana Elsa and
Anna are all modern princesses so it
would only be fair they stay together
have you spotted them when vanellope
first appeared they were chillin in the
back together Moana was casually resting
on her boat paddle and by the looks of
it they're having a pretty awesome
conversation we really want to know what
they're talking about you can also see
her be chill with Merida and the excited
Rapunzel next to her this version of
Moana is wearing the heart of defeat II
on her neck which is pretty awesome but
we also love that she's dressed in her
typical clothing from the movie but
seriously what are these Disney
Princesses actually talking about they
look like they've known each other for
years and they're immediately able to
become each other's BFFs chilling with
Rapunzel but that's not the end of Moana
we see her again in one of the more
recent stills that managed to break the
entire internet again Twitter went wild
after Disney released the image of the
Disney Princess slumber party we're
still not over the fact that we'll get
to see Disney Princesses casually
hanging out and talked to each other all
in the same room seriously
we're not over it but have you noticed
mallanna she's just so chill about the
whole thing
she seems totally smitten with vanellope
and we can't blame her considering how
cute she is we can't see what she's
wearing in full but from what it looks
like she has an orange top on
considering other princesses have some
sort of lounge where we can imagine
Moana will most likely be wearing either
pants or shorts
seems strange to see her in regular
clothing but it seems even stranger that
we haven't seen her in a while and we
saw all the other Disney Princesses you
can even see that Rapunzel looks like
she's totally laying on Moana was this
done because they couldn't figure out
what kind of clothes they want to give
to everyone's favorite Island princess
we've discussed the awesome casual
clothing Disney Princesses wear in one
of our previous videos and Moana
definitely wasn't shown enough to come
to any conclusions whoa
to wait until the movie comes out to see
but have you noticed the detail that
left Twitter totally shook this entire
record Ralph - has already been a wild
ride and the movie hasn't even dropped
yet but this one detail really proves a
Disney Theory fans had for years
baby Moana have you noticed it there are
several tweets out there that managed to
get viral thanks to the very first
wreck-it Ralph - trailer and they're all
equally as confused with this scene that
so many people managed to overlook this
tiny little detail just proves that
there's way more to unpack from the
trailer than just the scenes with the
Disney Princesses of course it's totally
understandable that people were so
excited about seeing all of our favorite
Disney heroines in the same room but we
totally forgot to focus on other parts
of the trailer the moment is already
becoming a huge meme and many have
turned their tablet screamed into their
own version of what the baby is actually
looking at but that's not what you
should be paying attention to did you
notice the baby actually looks similar
to baby Moana from the actual movie just
look at her features the skin tone the
nose the big brown eyes the short hair
it's totally her even the eyebrows
totally matched to the cartoons
character we saw running toward the
ocean and trying to grab the heart of
defeating before it got washed away we
have no idea what the baby Moana will
actually be doing in the record Ralph -
movie or if this in fact is a baby Moana
but you can't deny that the similarities
are too good to be ignored if anything
this proves a very important Disney
theory that has been explored plenty of
times before if you watch our Disney
videos you'll know that we covered the
topic that all Disney movies are somehow
connected with each other
Disney even admitted they've connected
the movies themselves from Alexa ball to
several other small objects you can find
in almost every Disney movie ever made
they really do know how to keep their
fans engaged with the movies so could
this be yet another easter egg Disney
decided to throw in one of their movies
wreck-it Ralph - is already full of
Disney's scenes so maybe this one they
made it's slightly more difficult to
find and difficult to guess why these
characters and objects are there in the
first place we know it wouldn't actually
make sense considering baby Moana was on
the island and this little baby looks
about the same age but it really does
make you wonder what's up with the
similarities all this version of baby
mallanna's missing is Maui a chicken and
her pig and
the Easter egg is complete but is it
real or is it just a simple character
recycling will this be the alternate
reality is this the reason we see Disney
Princesses all in the same room the
movie is all about breaking the internet
so who knows maybe they'll bring us
several different alternative realities
we've never even considered before like
Disney Princesses having a total
different role as babies baby Moana
hasn't returned to the second trailer so
perhaps her role isn't as important as
it might seem what do you think do you
have your own theory about baby Moana in
wreck-it Ralph - make sure to watch the
trailer again and give us your opinion
are we just imagining all of this or is
it actually baby Moana how would that
even be possible
our heads are about to explode from all
these questions so make sure to come to
bait in the comments we always love to
hear your thoughts wreck-it Ralph 2
comes out November 2018 and you know
we'll be watching and posting new Easter
eggs and theories and that's it for our
video thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]